when I thought this Senor reject those I
don't know what I said he's a good
afternoon mr. rejected this sounds like
what I was going for we're gonna watch
from a watchmojo.com another top ten
underrated actors so this is a topper
war tier video requests from loyal
patronage at Cameron French show he
requested top ten under a dead male
actors last month but that video is from
a few years ago this video is actually
just from 2019 with the Golden Globes
recently happening I don't know how that
links let's watch it yes yes yes yes I
love this list already
Forrest Whitaker is heavily under a
human yeah from a few years ago in the
last chat I had no clue who was who
but we know who you are we know and I'm
there for Blood Diamond I think you may
have done a supporting act or not for
those
many films including gladiator and Blood
Diamond the latter which earned him an
Academy Award nomination in the category
of Best Actor
[Music]
with acting chops like this he certainly
deserves a spot on the a-list is it a
quiet place - yes reject Maleficent
hardcore Henry man hardcore Henry not
the epitome number 10 oh I'll meet you
there
he's pretty known he's a known
unfortunately his transition deleting
call me by her name sucked right I
really love this man yeah yeah on gone
in hair advice and 12 years of slave
filmography impressive he's best known
first turn is Omar little
our discuss characters in television
history on the influential HBO series
The Wire falls into a similar categories
Paul Giamatti and the weak Philip
Seymour Hoffman in the sense that he's
an actor's actor a man who's made a
career as a brilliant supporting actor
robbing his debt to become a
conventional leading man Andy Serkis
give it
his own school acting no Kong says hard
oh yeah he's master creek where's your
brother we just stepped out of the
shower we'll be done
[Music]
we is a really great a Westar oil tip
over these grapes know primarily for big
parts Simpson consistently turns in
unforgettable performances Venus Gavin
or Sam of house of cards or as Wow the
intern on The Late Show with David
Letterman I didn't know about that
number three Michael Shannon some actors
are just so unbelievably consistent and
yet just like countless roles in Andy
flips and blockbusters never see
themselves become household names
what oh right
get cold feet you decide better off here
after widely respected in the industry
Michael Shannon is sort of actor that
every film enthusiasts is happy to hear
being cast in a role hell yeah it means
the character is going to be done
justice for casual cinema goers on the
other hand he's a familiar face but one
whose name they rarely read about and by
extension never managed to remember
about this man was also on the boardwalk
empire in general these comedic
abilities may have been with him I get
qualms of what you mean by underrated
[Music]
things of New York The Aviator and
Chicago the latter of which earned him
an Academy Award nomination new [ __ ]
man come on Mike the best pranky Badgers
more can you believe that the brothers
also had a role in Gangs of New York
yeah before we reveal our most
underrated top pick here are some more
than worthy honorable mentions for six
months setting up the restaurant and
I've grown to love it like the daughter
which they're gonna have been Bruce
Greenwood after he left on his route
how come I haven't heard Jenkins and do
or the guy from Watchmen Rob that I love
whose name I keep forgetting the show
the movie the show glass face nice
no attended Lake Nelson yes how's Tim
Blake Nelson the homeless let's keep
every number one that's much more that
guys just be sure to subscribe to our
Channel and ring the bell to be notified
about our latest videos all right back
to business
number one thank Foster from humble
beginnings okay Ben Foster has grown
into a talented I'll be criminally
underrated mature performer though he
never made the transition to heartthrob
leading men or a Lister
this versatile thespian has worked
diligently in the industry what a
compliment if espy in the versatile
there's really a bad guy he does
transform [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah this is
good good no good number one is to bury
her ated he's good awful
deserves Tim Blake Nelson should be on
this list John I'm gonna name off some
faces you fill in the names
okay okay the sheriff and watchman he's
them to Jamie Lee Curtis his husband and
knives out Don Johnson Don Johnson
should definitely be on this list is a
great actor and these are the resurgence
too he can command a screen with so much
charisma and he could do comedy and
drama Richard Jenkins that ever say that
yeah well I'm saying it again my name is
name though Richard Jenkins Jenkins
Jenkins I don't know why he's not on
this list let's start off I'm like yet
definitely underrated it and other ones
we're like well they're famous
I guess maybe there's an argument they
should get more proper leading man roles
for some of these I was like are they
not being as respected for their like
dramatic chops as they ought to be like
john c reilly made me think of that it's
like maybe a lot of the mainstream knows
him from comedy stuff because more
recently that's been more of what he's
doing but if you look deeper into his
career he's had a whole bunch of
character roles well he's never quite
had a strong leading man role I think
walk hard has definitely become
something of a cult comedy classic yeah
for a lot of people Boehner initially
came out it was a major flop but I love
that movie isn't my favorite comedy so I
think that's one of the most I think
whenever people ask me like underrated
movies I tend to go to walk hard has one
of the most underrated movies I quote
that movie like on the weekly hilarious
Djimon Honsou is a great pick yeah
fantastic pick he's someone who should
definitely be getting more leading man
roles it bums me out when I see him in
like the big movies because I know when
we like covered a quiet place to trailer
you really you even know made a comic
dumb I hope he has a real role his
normally that he just gets put to waste
all the Marvel movies and even in Shazam
and like asking the Furious yeah exactly
good then you see movies like like when
we listen here I'm a saw gladiator Blood
Diamond he's incredibly as an incredible
actor good luck surviving the apocalypse
in a quiet place rooting for you but
he's yelling at people all the time I
don't die first
sharlto copley is one of the most
underrated actors in hardcore Henry
played so many different characters
again an actor who can bounce between
comedy and drama like nobody's business
yeah and really disappear into
characters and really being different
personality every time yeah the
mannerisms the body language everything
about him sharlto copley so sexy so sexy
you need more of him they brought up
Andy Serkis too and I mean like props to
him because everybody goes straight to
Andy Serkis for mocap but like chappie
is a pretty great physical performance
to just to credit his physicality John
we are like two people on the planet who
like chappie hey we got to keep that
torch alive yeah it's gonna be there
will be cult status soon yes and
everyone's gonna be like where's those
chappies krita's survived Jami unpopular
opinion or not not the biggest army
hammer fan uh I'm not like a big army
hammer fan but I think he's a good actor
I think he's fun and charming but I've
never quite seen a role where I'm like
that's a man who deserves more yeah I'm
like I'm always pleasantly surprised to
see him places like I liked him and
sorry to bother exactly I like his
smaller roles more omi her name everyone
raised about Timothy sha'lame yeah those
both of their movie they even rave about
Timothy Shaw and his dad in that movie
Michael's still work doesn't bargain
yeah I think it's cuz he came onto the
scene of the social networking rules
like he played twins so well there's a
classical quality about him like kind of
like from an earlier era he doesn't have
like a classically handsome leaning like
I get why he got to be the Lone Ranger
even though it didn't work there's
something about him that doesn't feel as
versatile as well pretty much every
other actor on this list that's one
thing that's like I would love to see
Armie Hammer really stretch his legs
like I thought his role in sorry to
bother you was nice and kooky but not
without his realm that I'm used to yeah
it would be cool to see him disappear
some Michael K Williams oh yeah this
video covered it amen yeah he should be
higher up on the loose I think oh yeah
especially because of the wider that's
like one of the most beloved TV shows of
all time yeah yeah I mean a lot of
people forget
oh no credit The Sopranos but then
people who are like real you know TV
files where the hell you call HBO yeah
like but it's the wire yeah really it's
the wire yeah well I'm I know
very little about the wire I'm ashamed
to say but Omar is like the thing I know
about the why I think Andy Serkis is a
highly underrated actor for sure we
don't realize how he's in pretty much
every major franchise he's in Marvel MCU
yeah he's in Lord of the Rings he's in
Star Wars took on King Kong and there's
plan of the ages oh yeah well the thing
about Andy Serkis too is there's so much
great mocap work but I also think he's a
great actor when he just shows up
physically on screen like the one that
felt the most human was Snoke to me
that's not something that I would think
would get an Oscar nomination but I
rewatched last Jedi last month and I'm
like damn Andy Serkis kills it in this
role arguably could be a role that's
like under makeup because it's so human
unlike the other role that he plays yeah
it would feel more like animalistic to
nature yeah Justin Theroux
he is actually a tour de force of a
talent yeah writes directs acts and I
feel like a lot of people yeah you know
what a lot of people don't really give
him the credit he deserves I feel like
he's a name that would fly over a lot of
people's heads and then once you start
filling in the credits they'll start to
go oh he's spammed across so many genres
too I mean like he's in Mulholland Drive
like with surreal David Lynch he's the
kooky DJ and Zoolander and then
everything between he's another actor
who can transform oh you know who else
wes bentley is another actor if you like
a lot of the actors from American Horror
Story are very underrated okay Evan
Peters Evan Peters great to me is the
next job let me try it up was great I
feel like Johnny Depp and and I think
wes Bentley is another fantastic actor
sans a couple people I feel like
American Horror Story is kind of like
underrated actors the show them and then
made that hi Jimmy Simpson
he is so great every single time I watch
him I forget about the other roles I've
seen him in that I think he can only do
this kind of role so I watch him and
it's always sunny and I'm like okay I
can only see him as this watch him in
West world only scene that I forget oh
yeah wait he's done like a wide variety
of performances I didn't even know about
that David Letterman won no I didn't
either and I loved that too and when
there's not really much of that in this
list but those ones that even break
outside the traditional narrative format
and they just show up to do like a kooky
live bit like yeah you know that's also
a different talent of it in and of
itself if Michael Shannon busted onto
the scene in like the 70s I think he'd
be a superstar oh he would he would be
but there was something between Oh
Dustin Hoffman's he would be up there
with them I think it's just because of
you know the celebrities that we put
front and center who are based more on
personality and who can get really hot
but Michael Shannon though is that actor
who if he came out in the 70s in New
York actor he would totally just be
super famous he's funny his blog do you
like yeah I don't know if you guys have
seen his interviews we've randomly was
on David Letterman last minute to fill
in for someone he's so weird and then to
report a variety of those the actors on
actors we're like just two actors talk
to each other and it's him and Adam
driver and it's like an experiment in
never breaking like here so
straightforward and dry and never smile
it's kind of it's really awkward to
watch it but it's like a no 40 minutes
of that just being down okay yeah and I
love it isn't there an irony to it or
are they just really serious no there's
an irony to like I resent him another
interview said no they got it they they
crack smile they laugh but it's yeah you
pick up on a while like they probably
made some note beforehand it seems like
he does get a lot of work in period
pieces yeah like yeah it goes to support
your point that much more I think Ben
Foster probably hasn't broken out
because his most memorable roles are
tend to be the villain roles just look
at what they showed you who you like
3:10 to Yuma he'll high water or is it
like makeup on any and he is transfer
usually the transformation actors take a
lot longer to break onto the scene Gary
Oldman for example I used to play a lot
of villains Ben Foster as a hero and was
Angel x-men oh my god his perfect
posture and his big angel we discuss it
so naturally weird creepy thing about
him yeah it's easier to accept him he
looked like a quiet kid who might snap
but yeah that's the only reason he
hasn't you know exploded onto the scene
in terms of leading man roles but yeah
he is a very underrated
yeah there's something about the way he
just embodies mannerisms that almost
reminds me of like a Tom Hardy but in a
less marketable Tom Hardy way oh yeah I
would say Guy Pearce too was a good one
grab here so he just played Scrooge he
was great did he mm-hmm FX version which
Andy Serkis is also known as the ghost
of Christmas past bruce greenwood is a
great thing
yeah he's and he's been you know killing
it forever well he's one of those actors
too that when a director were so then
they seem to want to keep working with
him yeah like future projects like I
kind of support this by one statement Oh
Mike Flanagan mm Mike he's put him in
Gerald's game he has a role in dr. sleep
Oh who's the dad in hunting a hill house
oh wait which dad do you mean Gabri know
what uh they all hold old version I want
to say Gabriel burn but it's not it's no
but Gabriel burns go on you know who is
underrated also is the young death both
dads in hunting yeah they're both damn I
know his name and I can't pull you of
them to mind one was Elliot Nietzsche
and the other one yet Timothy Hutton
Timothy Hutton Tim hasn't them then
Elliot from et that's Elliot from ETA
great I had no idea
Oh Dan they're a great match for each
other to their yeah no that was the
coolest the other one because all right
guys well who do you think's in under a
male actor that deserves to be on this
list Cameron French I hope you request
next month for the females or little boy
actors the most underrated little boy
actors this list is 10 years old they're
all adults what is this crap this boy
did 20 credits thank you so much for
being here if you liked our video you
know the things that people say to do do
it instead of coming up with something
unique to say I'm just gonna say that
for help
Cameron thanks so much for requesting
this dude I hope you had a Happy New
Year hope you didn't get too drunk my
friend
I hope you had a wonderful Christmas let
me know and messages what you got for
Christmas dude because I want to see
what special naughty toys you guys hope
Santa this year yep pervert
yeah your sexy little pervert you know a
little he's an adult but he is
underrated and male and an actor in the
films we make to get and a little boy in
private